tout est prêt à viroflay pour accueillir
les donneurs les réserves de sang sont
fortement impactés avec les vacances de
la toussaint et les jours fériés du mois
de novembre
les donneurs sont moins disponibles
chaque jour férié est un jour de
collecte en moins mais pour les patients
les besoins de poches de sang se
poursuivre
c'est les urgences et la chirurgie c'est
l'accouchement avec les femmes enceintes
le plus important c'est des personnes
qui ont un cancer et qui sont traités
avec de la chimiothérapie ou de la
radiothérapie
il y a aussi les hémophiles assez aussi
donc toutes les matières maladies
hématologiques les grands brûlés c'est
aussi les drépanocytaires c'est une
maladie génétique
il y en a beaucoup en ile de france la
durée de vie des produits sanguins est
limité 5 et 7 jours pour les plaquettes
et 42 jours pour les globules rouges
pour donner son sang il faut avoir 18
ans peser au moins 50 kg et être en
bonne santé
tout le monde en paix tu dois donner
parce qu'il ya des gens malades nous
aussi on peut tomber malade à n'importe
quel moment peut être victime d'un
accident alors si on ne le fait pas bas
un jury aura pas un don de sang ne prend
aucune heure dont seulement une dizaine
de minutes pour le prélèvement
cette trentenaire donne pour la deuxième
fois son sens le temps de s'enregistrer
puisqu'il ya plusieurs étapes devant le
médecin et après 2
naissances en même pas une heure je
prends ça peut aider des gens et nouba
ça nous coûte rien après leur don une
collation est proposée aux courageux la
prochaine collecte de l'établissement
français du sang est prévue le samedi 2
novembre à saint germain en laye de 13
heures à 18 heures à la salle de
réception de la mairie